what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have some great news about the
first episode of Loki season two right
now based off of everything that we've
heard about Loki season 2 and everything
that we've seen it's shaping up to be
phenomenal and at the very least we hope
that it's going to be on the same page
that the first season was and so far it
seems like it is going to be it has the
same Vibe has the same tone and I've
actually seen a lot of people online
mention this and mentioned this as one
of the big reasons they love the show so
much and the great news is that the
production team is the same the music
team is the same pretty much everybody
that was in charge of the vibe of it is
pretty much still the same it worked on
season one and worked on season two as
well and now we have a run time for the
first episode and a little bit of plot
details about what's going to happen in
the first and second and in a little bit
of the third episode as well we know
that there are going to be multiple
variants of Kang the Conqueror in the
show but it looks like it's going to
come down to two very specific variants
in the show possibly three there's a lot
of mystery that comes with the show
which is one of the aspects that I truly
enjoy not really knowing what's gonna
happen but we know that this is really
kind of the Multiverse project it's a
super important project to the entirety
of the MCU going into the Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars and Loki himself was
going to play a huge role in the whole
entire secret War storyline so let's
dive into it if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
Loki and the MCU in general and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 so Marvel Legends items or some DC
items as well we pick one winner at the
end of each month and the winner gets to
pick one item so as far as episode 1 of
season 2 of Loki is concerned the run
time is said to be 45 minutes long which
is great it's not short it's not super
long but I think most fans are going to
be excited that it's not a 30 minute
episode a 35 minute episode especially
because I think this project is one that
a lot of fans are really kind of putting
their faith into and are really excited
about now this report is coming from
cryptic HD quality on Twitter and this
account when it comes to run times for
episodes of the Disney Plus shows they
have a pretty impeccable track record
with it they've been right many many
many times about runtimes and I'm glad
that episode one is getting a decent
time because they're gonna need to
explain quite a bit and jump into the
story that's going to set up and drive
the rest of the episodes and we know
what's going to happen in the beginning
because they're basically picking up
right where we left off in season one
except they're adding a little bit of a
Twist to it now at the end of Loki
season one he went back to the TVA he
went back to Mobius and Hunter B15 and
he tried to warn them but they had no
idea who he was now we know why this is
now he is back at the TVA and it's not
an alternate timeline TVA thing or
anything like that it's simply the TVA
back in time which is very interesting
because the TVA itself exists outside of
time and they even actually kind of
address us this point in the trailers
that we've seen Loki is time slipping
and Mobius takes Loki to see OB and Obi
says I can't fix that it's impossible to
time slip in the TV8 yet Loki is doing
it so what we know is that Loki ends up
back in time in the TVA it's still the
same TVA however at this point in time
Kang the Conqueror is still the known
ruler of the TVA he hasn't invented the
guise of the timekeepers yet we know
that ultimately something will happen at
some point in time where Kang the
Conqueror or he who remains gets in some
sort of a situation to where he
basically needs to be anonymous he needs
the people of the TVA and perhaps other
people as well to believe in the time
Keepers and therefore he hides himself
but in the beginning of Loki season 1 we
go back in time in the TVA where the TVA
is known to be run and created by King
the Conqueror and we basically know that
Mobius gets back on Loki's side even
though at this point in time he's never
met him before but he gets back on his
side because of the time slipping it
freaks him out and it tells them hey
this isn't normal something clearly is
going on with this guy I need to hear
him out because this isn't supposed to
be possible and from there Loki tells
him everything and we even see a scene
in the trailers where Loki prunes one of
the walls that has the timekeepers on it
and behind that wall is Kang pictures of
Kang and in that scene on the floor
looks to be a head of one of the
timekeepers as well so it looks like
Loki just simply walks into the
timekeepers chamber kills them all shows
Mobius look the robots they're not real
it's this dude he who remains behind it
and we have to stop him we have to make
sure his variants do not destroy the
Multiverse and from there we know that
him and Mobius are going to set out on a
pretty specific Quest we'll get to that
in a bit but first big thank you to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you may know that I personally
use hellofresh and I love it it makes
cooking fun easy and it's affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit delivered straight to your door
and you might not know that they act
actually have seasonal recipes right now
since it's summer they have their new
fresh and fit summer menu so if you're
trying to get that beach bud but you're
also trying to eat really great tasting
food it's perfect for you right now it's
peak time for summer produce and
hellofresh make sure you get all the
best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than seven days for Quality
you can taste if you are trying to
impress your friends this summer by
doing some cooking for them hellofresh
makes it super simple they give you all
of the ingredients and tell you exactly
how to make each meal and the best part
is right now if you go to hellofresh.com
50 Cosmic you can use code 50 Cosmic for
50 off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com 50 Cosmic and use code 50
Cosmic for 50 off your order and free
shipping now something that we believe
happens that's been reported to happen
that I think a lot of fans are going to
be happy about is that eventually Loki
does end up back in his present time in
the TVA the point in time basically
where him and Sylvie killed he who
remains So eventually he'll go back in
his point in time and his relationship
with Mobius will be the same everything
they went through will have happened
Mobius will remember Hunter B15 will
remember Sylvie everybody we believe
that he is sent back to the present time
TVA because of a device that kihoi
Kwan's character Obi gives him from what
we know about obi's character he was
kind of there at the start of the TVA
working with Kang we've actually seen
this in the most recent trailer TV spot
we actually see OB kind of helping Kang
create the time Loom which is basically
how Kang or he who remains created and
maintains the sacred timeline So
eventually Loki is going to get back to
the present time with Mobius the same
one that we were with the entire time in
season one and they're going to go out
and seek well two different people
really one Sylvie of course obviously
but two a variant of King the Conqueror
and of course we know that one they run
into is Victor timely however a recent
report suggests that another variant is
going to show up and that is he who
remains and at this point we're not
really sure if it's the same exact one
from the end of Loki season one we want
to say no but of course anything is
possible in this series it could just
simply be another variant that is very
very close to he who remains but The
Insider can we get some toast tweeted
out he who remains x no but did say he
who returns yes check mark so he who
returns implies that it might actually
be the same one but some insiders have
called him a benevolent variant of Kang
which is true he wasn't really evil at
the end of Loki season 1. Well he kind
of was but he was a necessary evil he
did everything that he did pruning the
other timelines to keep King the
Conqueror away to keep his variants away
to stop and prevent a multiversal war
one that he already won that almost
destroyed the entire Multiverse so it
looks like in some way shape or form
Loki is going to be teaming up with the
variant of King the Conqueror at least
for a brief point in time because you
can never really trust any variant of
King the Conqueror yes there are some
good ones but at the heart of every King
they want to be the true ruler of the
Multiverse even if they disguise that as
keeping the peace and saving the
Multiverse from destruction however if
it is indeed the same he who remains
from the end of Loki season 1 there is a
chance that he could be legitimately
good because he has already ruled over
the sacred timeline for millions of
years and when he was describing the
story of the first multiversal battle he
said it was eons ago and for those who
may not know an eon is a billion years
and he literally said eons so he has
been fighting a big multiversal battle
and then ruling the TVA for billions of
years even if he was bad he could be
tired of being bad we know that he got
tired of running the TVA because he said
he's older than he looks and he's tired
perhaps he sees Loki and Sylvie as a way
to truly change things he kind of saw
that in them at the end of Loki season 1
perhaps he sees is that there's a
different way to go about it now but of
course we do know that Loki and Sylvie
eventually get back together it's been
told that they're going to explore the
Romantic side of their relationship even
more which is still kind of weird but an
epic Loki thing to do fall in love with
yourself I love it and I'm looking
forward to seeing other variants of King
the Conqueror batter variants and
possibly even better variants as far as
goodness is concerned either way we're
in for a wild ride with Loki season 2
and the first episode is a decent length
I'm glad it is I'm sure you all are as
well but let me know your thoughts about
everything in the comments down below
please don't forget to give the video a
like And subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest Loki and Marvel
news you can also follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf
baby